it had like 106 dollars in the bank and  like I said I had to sell my dog and  things were not looking very very good  uh my 40 car had just blown up so I was  taking a bus to work I had no no film  history no real film knowledge I was  just working from I guess Instinct and  so often I had gone to uh fight films  and or sporty films yes we're gonna go  out there we're gonna knock them out  you're gonna win I said no I'm not gonna  win I'm going to get destroyed but if I  can be Lucid if I could still be  standing on my feet you know what then  life isn't so bad at the very end of our  Lives it we can still say you know we  were never humbled we were knocked down  but we got up and I can say I lived life  with integrity and I took all the blows  as I still prevailed to really succeed  no man really is an island when you find  the right components in your life the  right people that gel with you then you  feel as though you you're invincible